an azerbaijani soldier kicks the
armenian flag out of the way in freshly
conquered territory in nagorno-karabakh
and hoists the flag of azerbaijan
in the capital baku the crowds go wild
this is a big win for azerbaijan
the first village the army says it's
captured in a region the country claims
is theirs
nagorno-karabakh a cause as sacred for
them
as it is for armenia the region's ethnic
armenian population are being forced to
flee
leaving their men on the front lines
roxanna hachiturian's 20 year old son
was called up three months ago
just in time for the worst fighting
between the two sides in 26 years
he always tries to give me hope that
everything will be all right
from his side he needs time to feel okay
but i don't really know how he is doing
i just need a peaceful life only peace
and nothing else
but peace looks very far away
tit-for-tat shelling today in the
karabakh city of stepanakert
and the azerbaijani city of ganja
[Music]
and on the front lines it is a mix of
old-school trench warfare
and modern drone technology the ultimate
reconnaissance and targeting tool
especially in mountainous terrain
there are few roads out of
nagorno-karabakh for the displaced to
travel and they
are targets too this bridge was hit with
a quasi ballistic missile
but it's still passable
the nearby armenian town of goris has
become a major stopping point for the
displaced
and for the war wounded both sides are
being very cagey about their casualty
numbers but we saw a large number of
ambulances pass
us on the road out of nagorno-karabakh
there are hospitals there but it would
seem
that they are at capacity because a lot
of the wounded are being brought
here to the hospital in goris and some
of them on to the capital yerevan
the church in gory spares the scars of
the last war
fought in the early 1990s at a cost of
at least 20
000 lives
54 year old has volunteered to fight
again
i'm not afraid at all previously i was
in the war in the 90s
and now i'm not afraid to go back to the
front line
the weapons system is very different now
from then the hopes and prayers of those
fighting
still very much the same dynamic
sky news goris armenia